OverWatch 2 has come under Fire not just
for the bugs but for the publicly
accessible custom games with themes such
as sexual harassment simulator it is
disturbing it has people asking whether
or not blizzard has done enough to
protect all of its player base
hey everyone just a heads up that the
story contains depictions of sexual
assault and forced birth keep yourself
safe and take care of yourselves I've
spoken on this channel a bit about the
rocky start OverWatch 2 has experienced
since its release I'm still trying to
actively learn about this game I still
don't know the names of certain Heroes I
mix Heroes up I don't know what their
abilities do I fall off the map I am
still learning when stuff like this
happens I literally cannot experience a
game at its fullest potential I lose out
on teaching moments like I said in that
video games have bugs stuff happens but
when your game is presented to the world
I have what I believe to be pretty
reasonable expectations that you have
the measures put in place to keep your
community safe but that is not what I
saw on Twitter last Sunday Lynn Magoo
had shared a warning on Twitter saying
do not let your children play OverWatch
my 12 year old son found custom games
within it one called sexual harassment
and one game that simulated female
characters being raped thankfully my son
realized it was bad closed the game and
told me don't play hashtag OverWatch Lin
is also the partner of famous twitch
streamer limit who added to this with
here's some screen grabs I found on
Twitter of this OverWatch 2 sexual
harassment simulator apparently it's
been going on since the first game it
would be easy for blizzard to prevent it
but they're not this is a game marketed
to 12 year olds the screenshots only
provided included sexual harassment
simulator trending and another
screenshot of many different rooms
called sexual harassment Simulator the
trending room had the description of
this is version 1.2 of the new and
unique sexual harassment simulator find
new friends live a normal life and give
birth to a child a quick search of the
YouTube channel brought me to two videos
of what appear to be the custom game
mode in action in this first clip a
player seen choosing to play these
sexual harassment simulator custom mode
where there then is text saying months
of pregnancy in the top right corner
eventually it seems as if the player
who's playing a character that is a
woman is stunned then tea bagged losing
Health until their death they respawn
with a mission changing the top right
corner to go home and then wait until
your baby is here according to PC
gamer.com when you enter it it forces
one player to play as Cassidy against a
team of strict female OverWatch Heroes
the top left of the screen instructs you
to flash to knock down your victims
which refers to Cassidy's old OverWatch
1 flashbang ability and then says to
teabag to which is written with spaces
seemingly to get around a word filter as
you crouch text appears on the top of
the screen that says raping enemy heroes
are then marked as pregnant and
eventually a torbjorn bought a spawn to
simulate a child in its simplest form it
is a game mode that simulates rape and
forced birth to make matters worse the
first video I showed you was uploaded in
May 2022 while the second video was
uploaded in January 2022. this has been
an available game mode for months that
was just one room I was able to find on
Twitter but there are other custom game
modes with questionable titles my
co-worker and I were not able to find
sexual harassment simulator but we did
find other rooms labeled as 18 plus or
with the phrase naked OverWatch 2 girls
naked anime girls and a lot for Tinder
watch according to that same report from
pcgamer.com blizzard responded to a
question about the sexual harassment
simulator a game mode saying
inappropriate or explicit content has
absolutely no place in our game we
immediately removed the user created
game mode once made aware of its
existence we are continually working to
improve automatic filters to prevent
inappropriate user-created content and
manually removing any that are not
caught by the system however that same
report confirmed that the unique
five-digit code that allows you to play
the mode is still available anyone with
the code could presumably turn it into a
public game and re-list it it's possible
to report custom game titles and
descriptions through a button on the
browser page but for instances like this
for the mode itself violates the rules
there's no easy way to communicate that
to Blizzard according to that PC Gamer
report these custom games with labels
like 18 plus are places to chill out and
voice chat in I do have a problem with
blizzard having all these rooms so easy
to find and accessible for the entire
population of Gamers some of which
include children the fact I was able to
find these custom games is terrifying
there are so many young kids who play
these games and would have access to
these environments kids play games kids
are encouraged to play games somewhat
and maybe a hote coming in here I think
it is great that kids can explore Rich
universe verses and dynamic stories
these game modes are absolutely not a
part of that they are inappropriate and
unsafe OverWatch 2 has 25 million
players all who can Mosey on over to
custom games and search for this or not
even search for it have it pop up as
trending should blizzard stop all custom
games from happening no absolutely not
that would be ridiculous however they
should moderate and filter their own
products well enough so that things like
this don't happen creating and playing
in game mode that stimulates sexual
assault and force birth isn't just a
game it is [__] up and blizzard need
to do better
foreign